when all the hype for Logan began way
back in March 2015
Hugh Jackman tweeted that it would be
his last time putting on the claws given
how many times Jackman is donned the
adamantium claws and played the
scrappiest mutant in the X Universe it's
no wonder that he's finally ready to
step away from the role but his
departure opens up a very big question
that's on every superhero movie fans
mind who should play Wolverine after
Jackman well it seems plausible that Fox
could cast a relatively unknown actor
there's just as good a chance we'll see
a more established actor pick up the
claws well you might not agree with some
of these ideas for replacements there's
a chance that one of them could be the
next Wolverine Tom Hardy here's the man
who's got the best possible positioning
going into this discussion Hugh Jackman
actually said outright I think Tom Hardy
would be a great Wolverine of course
that's assuming the Hardy would actually
want to be Wolverine since at this point
he pretty much had his pick of any movie
he wants at the very least though
there's no question that you get some
fantastic acting out of Logan if Hardy
were to play the part just look at
whatever this is Liam Hemsworth we
already know that playing comic book
heroes runs in the Hemsworth family so
why not make Liam Logan as it stands
right now though Thor and Wolverine
aren't even in the same movie universes
anyway so the family resemblance might
never actually be an issue should he get
the role but Liam's clearly proven his
chops as an action hero already so
kicking things up a notch and giving him
a chance to play Wolverine wouldn't be
out of the question for this rising
action star kid Harrington sure
Harrington's got a lot on his plate but
with Game of Thrones and all but when
the series has run its course it'll
probably be right about time for someone
else to step in and take over her
Jackman we already know that he's
capable of being a badass and he's about
to be as high profile and actor as 20th
Century Fox could hope to get in the
role it's a win-win for everyone
Penn Badgley the former Gossip Girl star
hasn't managed to secure a real breakout
role since wrapping up his run as Dan
Humphrey but for those who've been
paying attention
he's been turning critics heads in such
films as greetings from Tim Buckley
sibling and the paper store while also
fronting the band mother
not that we're discouraging the man from
his music career but this is the sort of
role that might lead him to drop the mic
and step back in front of the camera
full time Taylor Kitsch
to proving his mettle in almost 70
episodes of NBC's Friday Night Lights
Taylor Kitsch played the lead role in
back-to-back bombs John Carter and
battleship but even before those flops
he had a shot at entering the X Universe
by playing gambit in x-men origins
Wolverine that role didn't work out much
better for Kitsch than John Carter did
but he's shown that with a capable
director he can hold his own on the
silver screen and besides we've already
seen Chris Evans successfully hop from
one Marvel superhero to another while
Ryan Reynolds redeemed himself by taking
another crack at Deadpool after those
two superhero successes Kitsch getting
the claws might not be as crazy as it
sounds
ryan Kwanten given the amount of success
that came with an australian in the role
last time it couldn't hurt to consider
another Aussie this time around the
former True Blood star ryan Kwanten
could definitely fit the bill he's done
his fair share of action films including
blunt-force trauma and Northman a Viking
saga if he seems a bit like a left field
choice well just consider how much you
knew about Hugh Jackman before the first
x-men film elf 11 back then Dawg will
ban the Heather exactly Jared Padalecki
there's no way the CW is going to keep
Supernatural going much longer which
means that Sam Winchester's Jared
Padalecki is going to be out of a job at
some point in the relatively near future
he's proven that he can battle back
against the forces of evil on repeated
occasion so he's already got that aspect
of the character down he can just get
past all those years of working along
Jensen Ackles
and get in the habit of playing a lone
wolf they'll be perfect Aidan Turner
he's played a vampire on being human a
dwarf in The Hobbit and since then he's
been busy as the title character on
PBS's Poldark but Aidan Turner hasn't
yet had the chance to play a superhero
he has however received acclaim for his
performances in all three of those
projects so why not give him a chance to
brandish a set of adamantium claws and
really go for broke Alex O'Loughlin okay
we know that Alex O'Loughlin is a little
bit older than the other options but
there's nothing that says you can't play
Wolverine into his 50s he's done the
vampire thing on moonlight and he's been
playing a cop for many seasons now on
CBS as a y5o reboot so we know he can be
dark brooding and play the bad cop when
the need arises william levy
although cuban-american actor william
levy is better known for his work in
telenovelas and his stint on Dancing
with the Stars than action film 2016
song shelf in two such films
and resident evil the final chapter and
he's also been cast in Brent Ryan
Green's post-apocalyptic flick the veil
as long as he keeps up this kind of work
he's got a good shot at being considered
for the role Joe Manganiello Joe
Manganiello just turned 40 but he still
got the look the swagger and the
requisite sense of humor to kick ass as
Wolverine Manganiello is a veteran of
the sci-fi fantasy genre after his years
on True Blood and if you've never seen
that you'll probably recognize him best
as this guy from the original spider-man
plus he's been cast as Deathstroke in
the Batman could there be a more perfect
candidate Scott Eastwood given how easy
it would have been to imagine his dad
Clint stepping into the role of old man
Logan a couple of years ago
the father-son resemblance between the
two makes it pretty easy to picture
Scott Eastwood popping out a pair of
quads and giving supervillains the
business he's also been known to chomp
on a cigar on occasion which puts him
even closer to Logan territory without
even trying Daniel Radcliffe okay stick
with us here but Harry Potter might
actually be a viable possibility to play
Logan Oh goodnight day is that just a
character no seriously some people might
be skeptical even now but he's been
working out and expanding his range and
with films like horns and Imperium it's
no longer out of the realm of
possibility that he could plausibly play
a badass yeah okay maybe he's a little
skinny for the role but he's clearly
capable of growing the requisite facial
hair and given that there's photographic
evidence that is at least some muscle it
isn't hard to picture him bulking up
even further if the opportunity
presented itself and before you dismiss
any of these possibilities just remember
before I became Wolverine Hugh Jackman
was best known for his work in musicals
as a song and dance kind of guy not only
that but Wolverine has always been known
as a short character the Jackman is
pretty dang tall at six foot two they
don't count anyone out when it comes to
searching for the new Wolverine okay
even Harry Potter
after all if Radcliffe can pull off this
look why not Wolverine thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]